[Musique]
je
et iwate watts ou tu pour dire bonjour
tous demain
[Musique]
tiens je te guinée où on est et vous
vous avez trouvé
regardez bien oui j'étais là où vas-tu
encore du mont ventoux a tout tué a
l'intention de visiter tous les pays
[Musique]
encore est bien avec toi on voyage
rapidement en route
[Musique]
k
vous reconnaissez j'espère
[Musique]
allez hop allons voir pour un petit peu
près de 400 yens sera pas quelque chose
ça oui je le connais bien ce pays
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il ya où à tour tous qu'est
ce que tu as vu mais qu'est ce qu'il
fait mais lui c'est est-il fou tous
mais dans tous les pays on me ses manies
[Musique]
quoi
vous aussi et c'est pour construire ça
que vous détruisez vos jolies maisons
[Musique]
eh bien elle va être belle la terre sont
tous les pays se ressemblent si tous les
pays sont pareils
tu as raison à tous à tous on ne va pas
les laisser faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh bien
et oui les petits bois tu vois ton
reconstruisent et bien sûr dans le style
de chaque pays et voilà
chaque pays a son caractère et tous mis
les uns aux autres ils forment la terre
au revoir à tous à tous et merci
il